I'm getting ready for a lot of things a
lot of things it's spring so we're
starting to get the gardens ready and my
tomatoes are legendary here in my own
neighborhood my daughter is about to
start kindergarten next year and so
we're moving you just so she can belong
to a better school yet Imani yo estamos
sabes uncle homebody met negocio after
five years of raising my children I am
now going back to work
every day we're trying to get more and
more ready and more prepared big boy
coming your way yeah right now I'm
applying for jobs it's a look into what
the real world will look like after
college I'm getting married this summer
someone I really care about
I'm going to be in a play I'm going to
be little fish costume from a little
tiny fishes
I'm getting ready to retire soon
retirement means reinventing yourself in
many ways well we've been doing a lot of
home renovations but most importantly we
really just want to teach our dog to be
eating the trash and so we have high
hopes for 2015 that that's gonna happen
I've started a new career recently this
is a 5th generation company which means
a lot to me this country was founded on
hard work and it really feels good to be
a part of that I'm getting ready to do
something too
I'm running for president Americans have
fought their way back from tough
economic times but the deck is still
stacked in favor of those at the top
every day Americans need a champion and
I want to be that champion so you can do
more than just get by you can get ahead
and stay ahead
because when families are strong America
is strong
so I'm hitting the road to earn your
vote because it's your time and I hope
you'll join me on this journey